today on a anime zone a review of the
disappearance of Haruhi Suzumiya the
theatrical sequel to The Melancholy of
Haruhi Suzumiya you know what it's been
three years since I've seen that show
and we still haven't been given a proper
explanation of what Harry he is
is she a god is she a distortion in
space-time is she the answer to Otto
evolution or wait what did iski say not
one episode the elders in the
organisation believe that this world is
sort of like a dream that a certain
entity is showing us because it's all
just a dream
it'd be quite easy for that entity to
alter our reality oh [ __ ] it all makes
sense now
yep this is going to be epic
[Music]
quite a while back when I was a we known
names nobody trying to pass time doing
badly-written anime reviews I briefly
voiced my opinion on the news show by
the name of The Melancholy of Haruhi
Suzumiya or as I like to call it the
monologuing of a sarcastic get it's been
three years now and while I have grown
up my opinions of some animes have
changed over time my opinion of the
whole Harry he franchise remains largely
unchanged while still good the original
series was overrated by the masses the
fanbase still scare the crap out of me
at how they can an sarcastically declare
their God is a 16 year old girl who
plays the guitar in a bunny costume and
every time I see someone attempt the
Harry Harry codons I still can't help
but laugh at how utterly gay looks in
real life
[Music]
a my opinion certainly wasn't helped by
the second season either with Kyoto
Animation repeating the same episode
eight times with the whole endless eight
Fiasco though I admit it was funny
seeing all the faces of all the hairy he
fans starting off as a gleeful excited
grin as first episode aired and then
over the weeks having it changed from
this to this to this to this to this
event finally this so even though I
thought the second season with the NSA
was a hilarious depiction of Kyoto
Animation collectively bending over the
entire hierarchy fan base is
simultaneously [ __ ] them up the arse
Kyoto Annie would have to do something
amazing to earn forgiveness from his
fans for the eight episodes of complete
dribble and a sore bum and actually
convinced me that the heresy franchise
was something more than just a passing
fad fueled by the craziness of his fan
base and you know what they actually did
it the disappearance of haruhi suzumiya
is the theatric continuation of the
heresy franchise that hit cinemas in
February 2010 and follows the crazy
adventures of the SOS Brigade as they
try to save the world from total
destruction by keeping this hyperactive
get from becoming bored he said there
isn't really the storyline because while
the crazy adventures were the main
setting for the TV series Murray
actually follows Keanu in the wintertime
a time when he says it's too cold to
even move though apparently not cold
enough to stop girls running around in
short skirts one day he wakes up to find
out that Harry he and all the strange
disturbances surrounding her have
suddenly disappeared there are no time
travelers no Esper's no aliens no crazy
[ __ ] telling you what to do and I've
seen dawns on him that he may face a
crisis bigger than anything he's faced
ever before a normal [ __ ] life now
forget everything you know by the hairy
heat franchise cause this movie is
something totally different
see while the TV series are just mostly
light-hearted random fun the movie goes
for much more serious tonin is actually
plot driven rather than to usual oh no
we have to win this baseball game
otherwise the world will end kind of
thing and this movie definitely benefits
from that while the largest storyline is
quite predictable the movie managers
have thrown many twists and turns into
the plot that keeps you engaged in
guessing throughout but the biggest
thing I liked about this movie was the
fact that we got to see some bloody
character development and we see
characters act like they never have
before
see while I thought the TV series was
entertaining the thing that annoyed me
the most was how the characters remained
static and no one ever developed but
that is certainly not true for this
movie
no more obvious is this with Yuki Nagato
a character who originally had the
personality of a rock I mean seriously
but what does Miri I don't think her
facial expression changed ever
this is Nagato with a happy face and
lugged her with an excited face assist
Nagato with a serious face and this is
Nagato with a [ __ ] above her face
because I got bored in the mood
we get to see a whole new side of Nagato
he turns from a robotic personality into
just as shy normal girl and the voice
actress both in English and Japanese
managed to capture this new humor son of
Nagato perfectly but the person who got
the most development was most definitely
keown since we get to see his journey
into becoming a fully active member of
the SOS Brigade while also being him in
his most vulnerable and desperate state
behind that fake aide of a cynical lazy
sarcastic wanker whose monologue
e-invoice are basically minor thoughts
though then again if he really was my
own inner force then it would definitely
have a bit more swearing I will probably
go something like this
okay I'll ask you someone how long they
believe in Santa is so stupid you can't
even consider the topic suitable for
idle conversation but that might just be
because I'm one of those pessimistic
douchebags sucking the fun out of
everything but that's beside the point
for millennia people have referred to
such an entity as God or something
similar
shut up it's ki you're talking mice tits
okay say I believe you what kind of
entity does that make Hara either
oh wait I seem to have stopped giving a
[ __ ] and that's when I met her
as far as the animation of music goes a
TV series is gorgeously animated enough
so you can imagine what a studio can do
with the same budget of a 14 episode TV
series squeezed down into a movie and
the music consistent of classical and
orchestral music that suited the grand
the scale of the film which had far more
of an impact for me than anything else
in the original soundtrack and to top of
the amazing animation great soundtrack
refreshing character development and an
unpredictable plot the movie was
surprisingly well epic how epic gotta
love that sound no seriously though the
best thing by the stream was that it was
just so well executed and everything
just worked from scene kion's
desperation as he realizes the bodies
and to the twists and turns that build
up to the final revelation just
everything about the movie George your
inner man is just to engage you while
keeping you on the edge of your seat I
mean there were some scenes in this
house so well done that actually got
goosebumps several times which I didn't
even think was possible for this
franchise but I suppose nothing can be
perfect and if there's one thing that
could be held against this movie it's
the slow and dragging start yes I know
the start was done deliberately slow and
dull to emphasize monotone boring well
without Harry here in it but I think
they dragged it on for just a bit too
long and unless you're a die-hard Harry
fan you could easily end up getting
bored since the first part this film can
be basically summed up with cure and
running around going war
where's hurry and then we see you keep
larger than half the Harry fanbase
simultaneously comes also to truly enjoy
this film you have to have seen the
first and second season already which
could be quite off-putting if you're not
already a harity fan overall the
disappearance of haruhi suzumiya did
something I never thought I could do in
my entire life and turned me into a
bonafide heresy fanboy it's movie that
he's a wet dream for Harry he fans but
even if he didn't like the TV series you
still might enjoy this everything about
this movie from the plot to the music to
the execution was top-notch and even
though I complained about a slow and
dragging start I didn't even really
notice until my second viewing and some
feedback I got from friends so
congratulations Kyoto Animation you have
officially turned me into something I
thought I hated if I was wearing a hats
right now I will take it off yes enough
set myself with some pessimistic Murray
hating bastard but [ __ ] you this movie
was great and if you have a problem with
this becoming one of my favorite anime
films ever then you can take it up with
this person
oh [ __ ] the tree was collapsing
[Music]
[Music]